We know the Republican
presidential field will grow by three
this week.
Mike Pence, Chris
Christie and Doug Burgum
all have announcements teed up
that will get us to ten declared
GOP candidates Will that be it?
Or will there be more?
Chris Sununu has been a maybe for months,
a Donald Trump critic
who is also
the popular governor of the state
with the first primary
on the Republican nominating calendar.
Well, today,
Governor Sununu is ready
to share his decision right here.
CNN's Dana Bash live in New Hampshire
with this exclusive interview.
Dana,
John, thank you.
And, Governor,
thank you so much for inviting us here
to the Granite State for your decision.
Yes.
So we've taken the last six months
to really kind of
look at things where everything is.
And I've made the decision
not to run for president
on the Republican ticket in 20, 24.
And obviously
a lot goes into that decision.
But it's been quite an adventure.
But not the end of the adventure
by any means. Why?
Why won't you run?
Well,
when you look at
what's happening out there,
you obviously have a very large field of
I think the former president Trump
is doing much better
in the polls than folks thought.
And when I looked at
where my voice can be,
how we make the Republican Party
bigger,
the responsibility that I think
I have in terms
of focusing
on the Republican Party
and ultimately focusing
on the opportunities for the country
and having a little more of a candidate,
a little more unleashed voice
and getting folks
to not just worry about, well,
is it a vote for Chris Sununu?
I'm not worried about that.
I want more independence
on the Republican Party team.
I want more young voters
I'm tired of losing U.S.
Senate races and governors races.
And clearly, I talk a bit candidly.
I think as folks appreciate
I think more folks
within the Republican Party
have to have
that kind of voice,
that kind of emphasis of message.
And making sure
that this is about the Republican Party,
not just about the former president,
but part of your decision
is about the former president, right?
Is it?
Oh, sure. About the size of the field.
They're 12.
By the end of the week,
there will be 12 candidates
for the Republican nomination,
and you're not going to be one of them.
But you think that's too big?
Well, it's look,
I don't mind
who gets into the field,
but given where the polls are right
now, every candidate needs to understand
the responsibility of getting out
and getting out quickly
if it's not working.
And I can be more candid about that
as the governor
of the first in the nation
primary, calling
candidates, candidates out, saying, look,
you gave it a try,
you're still in low single digits.
You've got to get out of the race.
And I'm not by when.
What's the Christmas at the latest?
If we do what we did in 2016,
you're going to have
somebody win this nomination
with 35% of the Republican support.
That's not where we should be as a party.
That's not where anybody wants to be.
But it's not just somebody for you.
It's Donald Trump.
Well it is.
But again
it's somebody who is in the past
he he served the country.
Thank you for your service.
We have to be a party in a country
that goes forward.
And if we're only talking
about Donald Trump,
then we're only talking
about relitigate elections
or January six.
We're only talking about yesterday.
But this is the United States of America.
As a kid,
you got to be
what you're going to bring to the table.
How are you going to change things,
what you're going to do?
And that's what gets people excited.
Governor, you wrote an op
ed for The Washington Post, and in it
you said a few things
that I'm going to ask you about.
But one,
just on this issue of the big field,
you said the candidates should not
get into this race
to further a vanity campaign, sell books
or audition
to serve as Donald Trump's
vice president.
Do you think that's
what some of them are? Absolutely.
Oh, it's very fair.
I mean, look, I don't want to
I don't want to be overly critical
until we see them on the debate stage.
Let's see who can take a punch.
You can give a punch.
But the message is very clear.
If you're not talking in residents
against the candidate who's right now
winning by 20 or 30 points,
then you're just potentially auditioning
to be on his team.
So let's get them on that.
If these candidates on the debate stage,
let's see who has the fire
to talk about the future of America
and doesn't back down, who can actually,
like I say, get
get a give a punch and take a punch,
knows how to debate, knows
how to show show strength.
And we'll see who those folks really are.
But clearly there's 12
people in the race.
I don't think all 12 of them
firmly believe that they can
be president.
I think a lot of a lot of them
just want to effectively audition
to be in the cabinet or
or vice president at this time.
There's no place for that.
There's absolutely no place for that.
Well,
you also on this subject, you say that
again that too many candidates
have entered this race.
They're simply running
to be Donald Trump's vice president.
That's not leadership.
That's weak.
It is weak.
But you want to be
you're not talking in generalities here.
But there are, again,
at the end of the week,
12 candidates,
you have to be
thinking about somebody
or you're a candidate.
I'll let everyone make
their own judgment today,
but I'll be very verbal about that.
I have a suspicion Let's be fair.
Let's let the process take place.
We're still a couple of months
away from the debate,
so I don't want to be overly critical
on any individual.
But believe you me,
I will be very vocal for folks
that are just afraid
to take on the former president,
afraid to understand
that the party is bigger than ourselves.
This job of running
is bigger than yourself.
It's not just about the vanity of it.
It's not just to get on the stage and
and sell books
or whatever it's going to be.
It has to be about the party.
It has to be about making sure
that the ticket
up and down is strong and right now.
Donald Trump
costs us from the US
Senate to governorships
to school board seats.
His message cost
Republican parties
dearly across the country.
So if he is the nominee
will the Democrats win?
Oh yeah. He can't win in November of 24.
Oh, the math has shown
Donald Trump has no chance
of winning in November. Of 24.
He won't even win Georgia.
If you're a Republican,
that can win Georgia of November 24,
you have no shot.
And he's proven that. So.
And not only has he proven it,
but the candidate
he gets behind in a good conservative
state like Georgia lose the race.
His messaging doesn't translate.
It does well with a hard core 30 35% base
but he loses everybody beyond there
and no one is undecided
about the former president.
There's no
there's no one out there going
well maybe I might consider voting
no you know where you are
he's a known commodity
and so the math doesn't add up
so if Republicans nominate him
then we're seeing a vote for him
in the in
the primary is effectively
a vote for Joe Biden.
I mean that's ultimately
how the math will play out
and you
of course we're in New Hampshire
and you are the governor of the first
in the nation primary state.
Will you endorse a candidate?
I suspect I might.
Yeah, I don't
I couldn't tell you who
right now
I mean, like I said,
I think everyone has to see
when they go to those
99 counties in Iowa,
when they sit in the living room
like this here in New Hampshire
and earn those votes we've seen
in the past
the fall, you see
candidates rise and fall.
Some go, some come
who can hold their own.
How do the debates Trump looks like now?
Well, look, they're all friends.
I mean, they really are.
They're all good friends.
And I hope they all stand up
and do the right thing
campaign the right way.
Talk about America's
opportunity in the future tense
and not just capitulate to the past.
Let's talk about a little bit more
about your decision not to run
because you said the path again
in this Washington
Post op ed,
the path to winning was clear,
but I believe I can have a greater impact
influencing the future
of the Republican Party
and the nominating process.
The beginning of that sentence,
the path to winning was clear.
If the path to winning was so clear,
why aren't you on that path?
Well, so a couple a couple of reasons.
When you start in as a candidate, again,
it's vote for Kristen,
who get on my team, my team, my team.
And so I think there's a responsibility
to think a little bigger than that.
It wouldn't have been easy.
But, boy,
when we pulled in a place like Iowa,
you look at what?
80% of Republicans,
something like that, don't
even participate in the caucus.
You got invited to the table
they want to have a voice.
They want a candidate
that inspires them and get them excited.
So when we did
all those numbers, while
the math was really they're not easy,
but a little unconventional,
but definitely a path and one I encourage
all the other candidates
to really look at.
But I'm more concerned about the party
as a whole.
Look, I'm young.
Maybe I could run in the future
or something like that.
But when I see what's happening
in all these other states,
state legislatures, U.S.
senators, governors,
former President Trump
and his message,
his style, his brand have cost us dearly.
And he doesn't represent
the Republican Party.
He doesn't represent that
limited government,
local control, individual liberty, stuff
that we all talk about.
He's he's about himself.
And I just want Republicans
to be about the Republican values
that have made a success.
Before I let you go,
I want to push back on that,
because if you look at the electorate,
if you look at the candidates
and what they're running on now,
most of them, not all of them,
they are running on issues
that are different
from what you just described.
One could argue
that you're the one out of step
with the Republican Party,
not the candidates. Running.
Oh, no.
Look at Utah Republican Party.
Well, maybe the base, right?
Maybe the base is
they're the ones who elect the nominee.
That's right.
And that's the frustration.
So I want to make the base bigger.
I want to get more independents
into the base.
I want more young people
that have been Disenfranchized
used to be part of the base,
but we want to get them back in.
You know, Gen Z, millennials
will be a bigger part of the voting bloc
than ever before.
And 24
if Republicans
just see that we're losing it.
So it's not just the Chris Sununu voice
it has to bring,
I think make the party bigger.
I want more Republicans
to stand up with this attitude of
how do we get the team
bigger, better and stronger.
So that base that you're talking about
isn't just stuck
in a narrow version of yesterday
it really has to be about
the bigger opportunity,
more fiscal discipline.
I mean, former President Trump
added a trillion to the deficit.
I mean,
where did the Republicans
go with fiscal discipline?
Or the opportunities on homelessness
and the environment,
conservative solutions to those things.
We capitulate
and hand it over to the Democrats
to give kind of socialist
green New Deal type
solutions that have failed miserably,
whereas we can bring real, real,
I think, opportunity to the table
and that gets people excited.
Governor, thank
you so much for your time.